bienvenue à voile autochtone si ces
milices à morlanne dupuis cette semaine
j'ai reçu une question de solvay et
qu'on va écouter comment c'était avant
la voiture de la nouvelle technologie
merci seul veille pour ta question ça
serait dur de duke il ya eu une vie
avant les technologies parce qu'on avait
des technologies quand même chez les
premières nations avant l'arrivée des
premiers européens et ses technologies
dans ont quand même été reprise par les
premiers arrivants je pense aux canaux
je pense au kayak je pense à la raquette
qui sont des technologies qui était
tellement bien adapté à notre territoire
qu'on les utilise encore aujourd'hui
tout ce qui change chez les matériaux et
à peut-être un peu l'apparence de la
raquette justement ou du canoë du kayak
mais encore aujourd'hui le modèle est le
même là aussi on parle de technologie
plus des technologies de communication
par exemple dans les communautés c'est
extrêmement important
pourquoi parce qu'on est souvent très
éloignés les uns des autres
on a des fois pas accès à la route des
fois nos communautés sont tellement loin
qu'il faut prendre un avion pour pouvoir
se visiter les uns les autres
alors là le téléphone les médias sociaux
la radio la télévision sont des moyens
pour communiquer entre nous qui sont
extrêmement importants tellement que
même les grands maillot des pages des
médias sociaux pour pouvoir voir des
photos de leurs petits-enfants qui sont
dans une autre communauté
donc on utilise beaucoup les médias les
réseaux sociaux là le téléphone pour
pouvoir se parler mais ça peut arriver
dès fois que certains
certaines technologies soient moins
bonne en longue distance donc on est
certain des technologies qui sont un peu
plus vient mais qui sont beaucoup plus
fiables comme la radio et on a beaucoup
de radios communautaires dans chacune
des communautés puis ça peut servir à
tous à dire rendent chez vous demandera
de recherche où on va faire un souper
communautaire ce soir mais les
technologies c'est certain que tout ce
qui peut améliorer la vie des
programmations vont être utilisés c'est
pour ça qu'on a adopté le métal qu'on a
adopté le verre des choses qui
n'existaient pas avant l'arrivée des
européens et qui ont servi à améliorer
la vie des premières nations
donc si ça peut améliorer la vie et pas
nous faire marcher de même que le salut
c'est certain qu'on va prendre ces
technologies là et qu'on voit les
adapter à nos cultures
donc je te remercie beaucoup pour ta
question je sais pas que j'ai pu y
répondre et j'espère que vous avez nous
en envoyer d'autres n'hésitez pas
surtout à partager les vidéos
je souhaite une belle semaine